Our epic three-day journey across the island...
...will take us 500 kilometers to Wakkanai,...
...Japan's most northern town, and finally on to Cape Soya.
As we battle through blizzards, colorful barns,...
...frozen seas and scenery, both jaw-dropping and utterly bizarre.
And because I don't want to freeze to death alone in a field,...
...joining us on the trip is my best American friend, Pete,...
...a presenter on Japanese TV,...
...who promises to drive me insane along the way.
But our road trip begins here in Hakodate,...
...the southern tip of the island.
In 1854, the city found its way to the history books...
...by becoming Japan's first port...
...open for trade with the West.
And that legacy lives on today...
...in its Western influenced architecture.
It's here not too far from the red brick buildings...
...that we grab a much-needed breakfast...
...at the iconic seafood market before we hit the road.
Oh, so it's 7 o'clock in the morning, guys,...
...and we're at Hakodate Morning Market.
Before we begin this long journey,...
...I thought, get some breakfast, get some seafood,...
...given that's what this place is famous for.
And also, it's worth introducing you to the guy...
...who's coming on the journey with us,...
...Pete, my best American friend, probably.
Thank you. I think you are.
That's quite a compliment.
I'm probably your only American friend.
Um, Chris, I gotta say, we've been friends for many years.
We have.
We met in a video game bar in Shinjuku about four or five years ago.